we begin tonight with a medical
breakthrough on two fronts the world
health organization has just approved
the first ever vaccine to prevent
malaria in africa this is a life and
death breakthrough that finally puts the
odds of survival in favor of the
children
most of the people who catch and die
from malaria live in africa most are
under the age of five
scientists say the malaria is far more
deadly than covet 19 in africa killing
more than 380 thousand people in 2019
alone
the head of the w.h.o calls the vaccine
a gift to the world and is urging
vaccinations to start across the
continent immediately
clinical trials were carried out in
seven african countries here is more
from the who's africa director
we've long hoped for an effective
malaria vaccine and now for the first
time ever
we have such a vaccine recommended for
widespread use
today's recommendation therefore offers
a glimmer of hope for the continent
we expect many african children will be
protected from malaria and grow into
healthy and productive adults
i want to pull in now ashley burkett
heads malaria programs at path that's a
non-profit organization focused on
global health he joins us from seattle
in the u.s it's good to have you on the
program how much of a boon is this
vaccine for the global effort to combat
malaria
well this is this is huge news and a
huge step in the fight against malaria
we've seen a lot of progress over the
last 20 years or so reducing malaria
deaths from over a million to under 500
000 but we're still seeing over 250 000
young african children die from malaria
every year and our progress has stalled
really the last five years we haven't
been able to reduce that number so we
really need new tools and to bring
and use in combination with the existing
tools to continue to drive down the
burden of disease in africa and is it
realistic to expect vaccinations against
malaria now to roll out across the
entire continent immediately
no it won't happen immediately and so
the vaccine has been piloted in three
countries in malawi ghana and kenya over
the last several years very encouraging
data on the safety of the vaccine
the effectiveness of the vaccine when
it's delivered through routine
immunization programs which are very
robust in sub-saharan africa often 80 of
children are receiving their vaccines so
we saw that slotting a malaria vaccine
into that existing infrastructure can
really be um
quite powerful but it's going to take
time it's going to take time to ramp up
manufacturing of the vaccine to higher
levels and first the next step is really
to ensure that the the financing and the
money available to buy these vaccines
for some of the poorest people in the
world um becomes available over the
coming months and does this vaccine mean
though that we can now finally
realistically talk about a time maybe in
the near future when malaria will be
completely eradicated from africa
i think it's premature i think it's
premature with um over 400 000 um people
still dying and as i said a quarter of a
million children the primary focus is
driving down the disease and death we've
got to get those deaths down to zero
we've got to see a day where no children
are dying from malaria anymore and then
we can start thinking about ultimate
eradication we're eliminating the
the parasite from some countries
certainly we're having success there but
still over 70 countries have the
parasite and many countries the primary
goal is to decrease those deaths down to
zero first and ashley let me ask you the
the rush to get coveted 19
vaccines out around the world did that
have an impact at all on getting this
malaria vaccine developed and approved
i don't think so this has been a 30-year
endeavor and this pilot introduction was
was started before the covet pandemic we
definitely think a lot about equity when
we think about covert vaccines and
making sure we're getting those vaccines
to people that need them around the
world not just in rich countries one of
the challenges with malaria is this is a
disease of the poor we don't really
focus on think about malaria every day
here in the us or certainly in europe so
we're really advocating on behalf of
those children and without a voice those
young african children over under five
who are going to benefit from this
vaccine so it's very different in terms
of the challenges to keep the focus and
and and bring something like this a new
tool like this to the brink of potential
impact in africa it's very different to
covert but um today's a historic event
and a really important step along the
way yeah and it's good to be delivering
good news for a change ashley burke
joining us tonight from seattle ashley
we appreciate your time and your
insights thank you
thank you
you